I'm not making any strong claims about
where science is going I think it's it's
certainly reasonable to expect that we
will understand our experience much
better than we do at the level of the
brain and there may there may be some
real impediments to that but it could
also be true that the sky's the limit I
mean we could really understand it in a
very precise way in such a way as to
allow us to to alter our experience in
in it's fine the grained way as we want
who knows what what awaits us there but
I know we're not going to get there if
we don't have an honest conversation
about the roots of human experience this
whole idea of secular fundamentalism or
atheist dogmatism and this is really a
play on words there's nothing that you
have to accept as Dogma there's nothing
you have to accept on insufficient
evidence in order to reject the biblical
God or in order to reject the idea that
the Quran or the Bible's is is the
perfect Word of God
there's no dogma that you and I have
accepted on insufficient evidence in
order to reject Zeus and Poseidon and
the thousands of dead gods that lie
buried and that's in that mass grave if
we call mythology these are these are
these gods were in good standing among
generations of our ancestors and for a
variety of historical reasons mostly the
ascent of monotheism they are now in
disrepute but they had the same
epistemological stature as the God of
Abraham I mean this is not like it's not
like there's so much data for the God of
Abraham and there's no data for Poseidon
they're both without data and it's an
accident of history that we are not
worshiping Poseidon and trying to
constrain our you know maritime law you
know in deference to the whims of the
you know the god of the ocean
there may be there's a value in
storytelling there's a value in
certainly in arts and literature and and
I think there's a specifically a value
in in narrative and there may be a value
in kind of taking on certain mythical
propositions as though they as kind of
schema through which to look at your
life I mean to you know take Joseph
Campbell's story of the net you know the
hero's journey and to think of your self
in those terms and just to look at what
features of your your life and
psychology that springs into view but I
think we have to be very careful about
making claims to knowledge about the
world let me take something like you
know tarot card reading you know someone
puts the cards down in front of you and
they you know they turn up you know
whatever it is the three of rods or
whatever look tarot card is and they say
well this you know this suggests to me
that you're dealing with issues of
honesty and have you been dishonest with
anyone in your life now there are two
ways to approach a situation I I you
know I think tarot card reading is
totally bogus as a metaphysical
instrument I don't think the the card is
is is doing anything important there
except it is causing you to ask a
question about your life I mean somebody
is just point blank a moment ago you
weren't thinking about honesty and now
I've just put this card in front of you
say well this tells me that you know you
might want to ask yourself this question
all of a sudden that may that changes
your your experience in the present
moment it may in fact gets you to
realize that oh yeah you know I had some
real work to do with my wife or my
father but the question is then what do
you let's say you have that experience
of a really valuable tarot card reading
you know what are you going to conclude
about tarot cards on the on the basis of
that I think you'd be wrong to conclude
that this is magic you'd be right to
conclude that there's a certain value in
asking questions and and that it's very
easy we know this is very easy to to set
up a system which has a psychological
resonance for most people most of the
time this is why astrology
seems to work for most people most of
the time you can give Charles Manson's
astrological chart to a hundred people
and 99 of them will say yeah well
there's you know they'll think it's
their chart and they think yeah this
really does kind of get me in some
fundamental way because there's no magic
to this things are written with you know
sufficient generality as to be evocative
for everybody because we're very similar